well visa and MasterCard have been
fighting to increase the transaction
fees The Interchange fees they charge to
businesses right and which will end up
by the way hurting the consumer because
what do businesses do you think they're
just going to take it and just pay the
extra 1% no they're going to increase
prices by Le they pass it on they're
going to make your sweater a little bit
more expensive George exactly and so
we're all complaining about inflation
while getting excited about our rewards
cards which are causing all of this to
happen because guess what visa and
MasterCard are not gifting you that out
of generosity that's the fees they need
to make money in order to pass on your
rewards and which in turn makes all of
the things you buy more expensive which
in turn makes you complain about
inflation they love those rewards so
those could go away George yes I would
it would be a a great thing a great day
in America a great day in America if we
had to live without a rewards which by
the way 30 years ago 20 years ago was
not even a thing